-How are you?
-So good.
-Back in New York from L.A
Does it feel nice to be back
in the city?
-You know, it would if I hadn'
left all my hair in L.A.
-Oh, no.
-Flew in this morning
and had to buy her.
Now she's here.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, New York City.
-There's nothing we don't have
-Honestly. Thank God.
-There's a lot of cities
you could have flown into
where that would have
been a crisis.
-Oh, my God.
I would have braided
a paper bag into my hair.
[ Laughter ]
Can you believe that was m
in that clip?
Did you guys know
which one I was?
-Yeah, that was fantastic.
-I was the guy.
[ Laughter ]
I had to grow a beard
for this show.
[ Laughter ]
-I do want to ask about --
you know, you have --
There are so many characters
in the show.
I think there's over
6 episodes, 100-plus characters.
-Yeah.
-Tell me how you -- a little bit
about some of them.
-Yeah. So, this is Chris.
-Okay.
-This is Chris.
You saw him in the clip.
So, you know how, like, you have
an ex-boyfriend and he's a jer
and then you guys break up
and then you get an HBO show
and then you have a characte
and you name him after him
and then you also
impersonate him?
Yeah, that's him.
[ Laughter ]
-That's it, okay.
That's good to know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who's this here?
-Oh, my God.
This is Dr. Hadasa Olayink
Ali Youngman, pre-Ph.D.
-Wow.
-Yeah. She's a hertep.
-Okay.
She's a woman who spouts
lots of conspiracy theories.
-Ah.
-And most of them
about white people.
[ Laughter ]
And yeah, she's fun.
-And this is really cool.
When you come up with
a character, you actually --
you will do a drawing of it.
-Yeah, so, my head writer,
Lauren Ashley Smith,
got this framed for me.
So, I drew her here and then the
hair, makeup, and wardrobe tea
which is just fantastic,
created her.
So these little notes say like
"Faux locks, blonde!"
All caps.
Green eyes. I don't know why
My eyes are green.
I didn't need to put that.
[ Laughter ]
An Africa belt buckle,
which I didn't get
but I did get
this amazing necklace
that our wardrobe designer
gave us.
So they're amazing.
-Do you think you put green eyes
just so it made it very clea
that you were gonna play her
Because I know --
-Yes, I had to,
because our cast is so good.
Gabrielle Dennis, Ashley Nicol
Black, Quinta Brunson.
They are fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we would have --
Yes, thank you.
For them.
But the applause for me
was better. I just want to -
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we all know this.
-So, we would have rehearsal
right before our table reads
right?
And we would -- because,
like you said,
we're playing 100 characters
between the four of us --
sometimes we would swap role
and just see
who would be better.
And I was like,
"Yeah, sure, you guys can read
a couple of my roles,"
And they stole every one
out from under me.
They are that good.
-That is good.
-They're fantastic.
-It's very nice that you,
as the show creator,
you appreciate that spreadin
the wealth is a sum positive
-I do and it was too late
to fire them, so --
[ Laughter ]
-You've got a couple more though
that you've got.
-Oh, this is Tina.
Oh, speaking of hair, honey,
look at her.
-Yeah.
-All the way down.
So, she's a member of
the bad bitch support group.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep. Thank you. Thank you.
And that group is headed by none
other than Miss Angela Bassett
-And how was -- Such a powerfu
actor, Angela Bassett.
-Oh, I thought you meant me.
-What is it like -- Oh, both
[ Laughter ]
Both of you.
-She's good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What is it like
to have her on set?
Was she a good sport?
Was it a blast?
-Oh, my God. She's amazing
First of all, she is just
such a regal queen.
She looks amazing.
You've met her. You know.
But she's amazing.
And she came on set,
and I forgot all my lines.
So I'm acting across from he
and she's acting and I'm like --
[ Giggling nervously ]
And they're like, "Cut, please
Can you act?"
And I'm like, "I'll try."
-Also actors historically --
comedians I think, think, "Oh,
I'll just get it on the day.
Like, actors show up prepared.
-Prepared.
She knew all her lines.
I had four and forgot them all
-And who are you here?
-Oh, yeah.
This is Claude,
of Claude and the Boppers,
you may have heard of them
-Sure.
-They're a Motown group
that sung a song
called "Ice Cream Shop,"
and then I decided
I wanted to change the lyric
to make them about sex.
-Oh, no.
-So I start humping the ground
and humping people.
You know, classic.
-All that and more you can see
on this fantastic show,
which is getting
such wonderful reviews.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It's so exciting to have
a show like this on TV.
And it's so exciting
to have you back.
Give it up for Robin Thede
everybody.